My next tudor was Rob Resnick, and Rob went
to MIT. He would come over, make sure I got
my math and my english done. He also became
like a big brother, which was really good.
He would take me over to MIT where I liked
to throw the baseball. He would take me over
to his frat house, where I seen the Dallas
Cowboys and the Green Bay Packers play -- one
of the first football games I got to watch
on TV. Simply because of the fact that my
mother didn't let me watch a lot of TV. The
students. When I first came 40 years ago,
when my father died, that's when I came into
the business, the MIT students were ... slovenly
attired. They had hair down to their knees,
some of them, they didn't comb it, some of
them didn't wash, most of them didn't shave.
They were pretty gross at times. As soon as
women came to the MIT campus, all of the sudden
it was a huge difference in the men. And they
took showers, and they shaved, and they cleaned
up. They were much nicer to be around. An
interesting dichotomy there between the old
MIT kids and the new ones. And I think it's
about 50 percent women now. Well, of course
people who are involved in that kind of stuff
are a little bit more idealistic than the
average, I don't know about the average student.
It's not like it was in the late 60s, early
70s when it was it was a massive amount of
social consciousness. The students were interested,
in those days, in us, as if we were members
of the same species. But normally they don't
think that way. Most of the kids who come
through Central Square, they act like you're
not there, you're like pigeons or something
like that. And I suppose if I went there that's
what I would think about them. But the ones
I knew, I still know some of them -- I've
made some good friends. And they still keep
in touch with me. Just a few. There's a reputation,
of course, that MIT students are very diligent,
they're much more serious, and maybe of a
different class background than the ones at
Harvard. Harvard has a reputation of frivolous,
wealthy students. Whether it's justified or
not I don't know. But that's what people think
when they think of the two.